Jocko,
I should have asked it in muster zeros or six.
Is there a dichotomy,
dichotomy in the unmitigated,
unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
And like I said,
this is why I put this question here because it's related to the question,
the answer that I just gave,
which is yes,
you can,
you can overdo it.
And there is a dichotomy.
You can put so much focus on working.
Um,
you can put so much working,
so much focused on working that you lose track of your family and everything
goes down town with your family.
Or you can do the opposite.
Put so much focus on your family that you lose track of that you don't do what
you're supposed to do at work.
Um,
so you need to back off a little.
Uh,
and you get people that waste time on things that don't matter.
This goes back,
remember the podcast we did where I was talking about how like a black belt when
a white belts globbing grabbing a black belt sleeve and it just doesn't matter.
There's people that think that it's important that I do this thing this certain
way and the reality is it's useless.
It doesn't matter.
You're being OCD,
right?
You're being OCD.
So,
or are you maybe not being full of,
but you're being borderline.
You've got to think about what's important and what's not important.
And if your disc,
if you generally or oftentimes people that are hyper disciplined about little
things,
a lot of times they're missing their discipline in other areas of their life.
And one of them,
and you,
we've talked about this before too,
which is somebody that just because someone is hyper disciplined in their
physical fitness doesn't mean that they're disciplined in their rest of their
life in many other ways,
whether it's financial,
whether it's their relationships,
whatever,
like everything that they can be screwing every,
they're super disciplined in weighing their food and doing macro calorie
counting and all that stuff.
Right?
And yet they haven't paid their phone bill or whatever and they've got financial
issues or they've got health like other health issues.
And so you need to,
you need to back off enough on the little things that don't matter that so that
the things that matter you can actually take care of.
Now,
the weird dichotomy in this is again,
it's always comes up,
the Russian soldiers in the Chechen war,
not shaving.
Is it really important that they shave?
Not really,
but what's really important is that they have discipline overall and when they
stop shaving,
they,
they let go of their discipline and that was the problem.
Now,
so you're there.
There is about,
that's what I'm saying.
There's a balance and it gets,
well,
let,
let me,
let me make that a little more clearly.
If we were in a war and what I was focused on was echo,
you better shave tomorrow.
That was my big focus.
Echo your uniform.
Better be squared away tomorrow like that.
That is not what the most important,
the most important thing is like echo.
Do you understand where the fallback positions are?
Echo,
do you understand what your field of fire is?
Echo.
Do you know what you're supposed to do when we start getting overrun?
Those are what's important and,
but if I focus on this little thing that doesn't really matter,
that can,
that can be a problem.
So I need to make sure that I'm focused on the correct things and in life.
Yes,
you can.
Unmitigated Day with discipline if you try to apply it to absolutely everything
in your life,
just like prioritize and execute.
If you try and solve all your problems at the same time,
you want people to solve any,
if you try and implement perfect discipline in every single thing that you do,
you won't be able to apply discipline to the things that are most important.
My garage gym floor is dirty.
I sweep it.
Sure,
of course.
I sweep it every third day.
I just sweep it out.
But I don't get in there with a bucket and a mop and try and clean the chalk off
so it's perfect black.
Why?
Cause it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
So some things in life are like your gym floor.
It just,
it doesn't matter if there's chalk on it,
I'm going to put more chocolate in it later.
The chalk doesn't make me slip.
It doesn't make me sick.
It doesn't.
It doesn't,
but I don't care how it looks.
So don't worry about the chocolate,
the gym floor.
In fact,
there's gyms in the world where you're not allowed to have chalk cause they
don't want chalk on the gym floor.
The those places shouldn't exist in the world.
They should be.
They should be illegal.
There should be chalk everywhere.
Yeah,
the gym available.
you're right.
So don't focus on things that don't matter.
There you go.
You didn't pan.
It's the,
it seems like the whole discipline equals freedom thing in whether you agree
with it or not.
Actually,
you know,
I think you will agree with this.
It's a dance.
You know,
it's the dance with discipline and freedom.
Do you mean about a balance of a dichotomy?
Yes it is.
In fact,
I wrote a book about the other.
Thank you.
I appreciate you pointing that out to me.
So,
and it's going to be,
should take ownership too.
It just depends on who you are.
Like you,
the discipline is going to be taking the lead big time,
you know?
And when you exercise your freedom with,
I don't know,
I don't know.
[inaudible] is like what?
Mint chocolate chip ice cream or something like this.
When you exercise that freedom,
it's not going to be very often,
but when you do boom,
it's going to have benefits and that's when you see somebody that's,
let's just talk about this.
Well,
when you see somebody that's out of shape,
you could say,
you could say one of two things.
You could say not enough discipline.
Right.
Or You could say too much freedom.
Freedom.
We know it's one of those two things.
If you see someone that's having financial issues,
it's one or two things.
Not enough discipline or too much freedom.
They're getting out that credit card when they shouldn't be.
Right.
So yeah,
that goes without saying that it's a balance.
It's dichotomy.
That's correct.
Yes.
Even and also on top of that,
the discipline in all things.
Cause that's the question right at maybe you could put,
maybe you could write a book called the dance.
The dance.
Sure.
Of leadership.
I'll just copy the dichotomies.
But the,
in all things like discipline in diet,
discipline in,
um,
uh,
you know,
workouts and not slacking and whatever.
And that looks way different than discipline in like relationships for example.
Like if you're like a diff like to,
to,
you know,
the discipline not to lose your temper or the discipline to,
to respond to a maybe not disciplined person or something.
Let's say someone you love who's,
who's maybe emotionally different than you or whatever that looks and feels way
different.
You know,
if,
if you really think about it.
So if you're like,
Hey,
I'm not gonna,
I don't know,
I'm not going to go to the park with my wife because I'm working out.
That's my discipline.
I'm no slack,
you know,
kind of lacking the discipline to organize around your relationship.
Exactly.
Right.
With your relationship or you're lacking the discipline to make sure that your
wife understands that you're going to train.
Yeah,
cause I don't want to train.
But as far as we're like,
and now that's back on the training in.
But like with like your relationships,
unless your relationships are important to you,
which is,
I mean I would,
I would argue most times.
So there's some relationships in your life that,
that are going to be important.
I would argue that there should be,
I think so too.
Yes.
So for maintaining discipline in those relationships looks different.
So it might not be as obvious.
So when someone says,
Ma unmetered,
when you say unmated gated discipline in all things,
I don't think automatically right off the top of my head.
Like,
Oh,
you know,
my relationship with my wife,
or even the relationship with your kids.
Like when I think unmitigated daily discipline in all things,
including my kids.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make sure they're disciplined.
Oh.
But the discipline of your,
of yourself dealing with the kids,
that's a whole different thing.
Seems saying true.
So you've got gotta kind of keep those in my,
well,
I've found,
I've found herself.
Yeah.
I find that when I,
when I keep that in mind,
it'll help.
And then,
yeah,
and do the dance with freedom.
You designate how much freedom you are going to uh,
exercise and then you do the dense.
Seems Sane.
You balanced the dichotomies.
What she do.
Yeah.
Yeah Bro.
You dance it.
And here's the thing,
here's the wrong thing.
What I made a mistake of at one point long time ago,
I looked at you and I was like,
shoot,
I need to do that.
I need to wake up,
I need to like do all this stuff,
whatever.
But if,
if I were to do that,
I jumped myself up.
So I can't like you can't use like the next person as the standards as far as
the balance goes.
Like you have to designate your own balance.
Yeah.
Cause you have to modulate for your life.
Whatever brought people don't just automatically know that.
I know I didn't check,
figured it out into you getting up at four 30 at any point though.
Yeah.
I tried to
check anyway.